I always wanted to be a rapper that was
my dream don't you dare laugh of my
dream toll this is a land of hope and
opportunity come over here you do
whatever you want that's why I'm here to
see you in it I'm the thing with rap is
some people they don't like Ickx they go
oh it's just just violence and it's just
drugs and yeah that's why it's cool
doesn't have to be me about whatever and
that's what I'm interested in if you
could hear a rap about anything in the
world what would it be about so so think
of a word think of a topic or a phrase
you'd like to hear a song about there
are three rules number one no food
number sorry over there already just
liked amyloid a rap about cheese
number two no no no animals suggestions
we've heard a lot about cats tonight I
love cats God can't call socks it's
pretty good we call it sucks because we
had to but lost one in the washing
machine
no animal suggestions no food
suggestions and nothing too obvious
don't don't suggest like brexit or trump
or things that everyone says keep your
mind out of the gutter as well the last
few weeks here people have been saying
gonorrhea and all that stuff nasty so
the best suggestion I've had recently
was ninth-century crop rotation
last night a lady sat on that table said
the development of retail in the early
Industrial Revolution so you can be
found with it well it will take five
suggestions so let's divide the room up
into quarters this this segment here
what's your suggestion there were two
umbrellas umbrellas get suggested all
the time for some reason I don't know
why I think it's cuz there's one in the
glass case over there what did you say
70s shag carpet is that inspired perhaps
by the thing this it's pretty it's
pretty cool in it 70s shag carpet I like
it this half of this half data science
someone over there's very upset I either
they were like well that's boring or
they were like he took my suggestion I
mean that'd be weird what are the odds
of that happening I don't know maybe you
can figure out but she want to pick a
specific aspect of data science because
that is quite a broad subject artificial
intelligence as an aspect of data
science I thought by asking that
question would make it simpler but
actually I've made it much more
complicated okay 70 shag carpets
artificial intelligence is a part of
data science you guys here you can
actually make it easier than that
suggestion if you want blues jazz
artists so like like combo artists okay
cool I do you have a particular one in
mind no no damn you are really making it
tricky tonight blues jazz artists AI as
a part of data science 70s shag carpets
guys over here what you suggestion there
were two at the same time so you said
Applebee's which is um just so I don't I
don't know many of your dining
establishments Applebee's is that a good
a good one know what what so I've been
to a Denny's I enjoyed Denny's it was it
was an experience
an apple what would I get from
Applebee's what's the basic order
someone over there said gonorrhea most
comedians would be upset they'd be like
oh it's taking my jokes genuinely that
was very funny what would be it won't be
a standard order of food that you'd get
from Oh gonorrhea shut up well be like
an Applebee's order chicken-fried steak
mashed potatoes that sounds good yeah
and someone over there said something
something at the same time as Applebee's
yeah I heard something like British
colonialism what was it British
imperialism do you have a specific
country that you'd like me to delve into
regarding that
I believe there's only about 11
countries in the world that the British
didn't invade at some point one of
them's Luxembourg as well rubbish
rubbish we could have had it we didn't
want to if you've got to describe your
country as it looks
no it's not so Brit British imperialism
what what what aspect of that then [ __ ]
in here oh gosh okay yeah I mean usually
this is like this is like the end of the
night right usually I try and make it
funny it's just gonna be a lecture so
British imperialism focusing on Virginia
Applebee's which I think's gonna be the
high point really if I'm honest 70 shag
carpet a I as an aspect of data science
and what was the other one that we got
under blues jazz musicians okay cool
this then lovely people over the Hamoui
Beach comedy and magic clubs gonna be a
little treat for you all a little thing
to close out the night a little thing
called a freestyle rap that is it's a
rap made up on the spot based in Tyre I
love the surprise of people there as if
they were like is he just gonna get
these words and then leave
oh it's just a survey it's a survey
that's what comedy is in Britain it's
it's or it's a rap a rap made upon the
spot based entirely on those suggestions
it will be you'll be really good none of
you believe that you're all going you
are far too English and white for it to
be good
we'll see can we can we play that track
let's let's get some volume on it as
well the beat go here we be I'm getting
my belly full in my local Applebee's
walking in like yeah I made a mistake
I'm too drunk now I wanna order
chicken-fried steak
bring it to me oh yes I know I'm gonna
get a side of the mashed potato damn
bring the gravy oh I go crazy I pour it
over there even though it's so pale see
in the UK gravies made from bone stock
it's like a brown color yes oldest
Woodstock but over here it's got like
little bits of bacon if you're in
Applebee's I hope you're taking
protective methods if you are there cuz
apparently you might get gonorrhea
everybody walking in together not able
they catch it as soon as they touch the
table gotta disinfect all the cutlery I
wanna work as a server and Applebee's
and advise everybody leave right now to
catch in diseases like Mad Cow that's
what we had I wasn't saying you're a mad
cow that would be so rude sitting there
like wow coming over here saying these
insults start in colonies Virginia was
our fault I'm so sorry that we came
across the seas we're like yeah we'll
seize everything we see we'll start
planting tobacco on the floor our
intentions were not at all pure we were
just sitting there maybe stop and think
to make the whole empire British Pig
imperialism that's what we did I was
taught it was a good thing when I was a
kid but now no it's not good I see you
on the news we did bad things so I'm sad
like blues musicians who feel that their
zambra is bastardized now it's blues
jazz words of my surprise you've gotta
play the 12 power chords and then
improvise madly with swords like
juggling knives or playing trombones
never was a musician no talent in my
home no piano either didn't know where
to start it just had a living room with
a magic carpet if you saw it you would
be out your mind
the colors clash so much you'd think
you're color blind from the 70s he's
seen a lot of action because shag carpet
the infraction that happened on his
Shack is a slang word for sex and that
is what went on in my house I expect not
between my mom and dad between the
people that live there before how would
you know this Chris is not something you
ever saw well I'm glad you asked me that
I've got to lots of paper that I brought
from my flat we're gonna shuffle through
it analyze it yet we save for later use
my a I helper to help with the data so
much going on on these page I need to
get projection of spreadsheets on stage
get AI by IBM's Watson that's a good one
in AI if you've got some knowledge bout
it you might say that's a lie but
someone over there was clapping they
probably work for IBM was that all of
them
[Applause]